Caption: all right hello everyone and welcome to
Caption: the second Talk of the day
Caption: so I'd like to introduce Christy Haynes
Caption: um he'll be giving the talk everyone's
Caption: confused about design and that's okay
Caption: sorry a bit about Christy Christy's had
Caption: over 18 years of experience in design
Caption: across a variety of delivery and
Caption: research roles she's currently a ux
Caption: design lead with hbf health and has
Caption: worked in both Enterprise and agency
Caption: organizations in Australia and the UK
Caption: Christy's proud to Define herself as a
Caption: design generalist she's got a broad set
Caption: of skills a good dash of Common Sense an
Caption: experience that just helps get stuff
Caption: done
Caption: Christy's passionate about Levering
Caption: leveraging design to help enable a high
Caption: performing cross-functional teams she
Caption: loves nothing better than working with
Caption: people in different roles to unravel
Caption: sticky problems and creating Innovative
Caption: digital products and experiences
Caption: okay thank you Christy cool thank you
Caption: Teresa um it actually makes uh yeah I'm
Caption: very proud that Teresa was actually able
Caption: to introduce me today um for those that
Caption: don't know either of us we go back a
Caption: fair while so she's actually a close
Caption: friend so it means a lot for you to
Caption: introduce me
Caption: um I want to just thank the organizers
Caption: the volunteers and obviously our
Caption: sponsors as well this is my first EDD
Caption: Perth conference so I thought why not
Caption: come in and do a 45 minute talk to start
Caption: with so it'll be fine come along for the
Caption: ride it'll be great
Caption: um
Caption: right
Caption: so let's get started
Caption: what is design so design is well that's
Caption: a really simple question but it's
Caption: actually quite hard to answer
Caption: it's something everybody's got
Caption: experience with in one way or another
Caption: and even if you had a room full of
Caption: designers and you asked them this very
Caption: question you'd get a whole wide range of
Caption: different answers back so it's no wonder
Caption: that everybody is confused about design
Caption: so a couple of months ago I was looking
Caption: around online on the old Facebooks as
Caption: you do and I saw a Facebook post from an
Caption: online design school that asked this
Caption: very questioned and I thought great
Caption: that's going to be two minutes of my 45
Caption: minute talk I can probably talk through
Caption: some of the answers that they gave on
Caption: that Facebook post so let's have a
Caption: squeeze at some of the things that they
Caption: are people said in the Facebook post
Caption: comments
Caption: so design is function Made Beautiful
Caption: design is the intentional creation of
Caption: amazing effortless artifacts
Caption: all that we see is design
Caption: is how things work look feel and are
Caption: used
Caption: so what comes to mind when you think of
Caption: design so for some people it may mean
Caption: things like designing things like
Caption: products websites apps Graphics or it
Caption: might be to say the way that something
Caption: looks or functions and you'd be right
Caption: these are all things that we refer to as
Caption: design but there are only a few aspects
Caption: of design
Caption: for about three years ago I was on mat
Caption: leave and I was getting a bit antsy and
Caption: I wanted to sort of watch a few design
Caption: presentations and there was one by
Caption: opherion Tov he's the chief design
Caption: officer over at ANZ bank and what he
Caption: talked through was the framework that
Caption: was developed by the Carnegie Carnegie
Caption: School of melon School of Design in the
Caption: 1990s and it talks about four orders of
Caption: design
Caption: so these aren't levels there's no
Caption: hierarchy here but just four types of
Caption: problem space is that design can help
Caption: with
Caption: and I found it really useful in the way
Caption: that it broke this broad concept of
Caption: design into something that was just a
Caption: little bit easier to understand because
Caption: design at its core is about problem
Caption: solving
Caption: so these are our four orders of design
Caption: they're based Loosely around product
Caption: type and ordered around complexity level
Caption: now this is all well and good but if you
Caption: actually went up to a designer today and
Caption: said hey what order do you work in
Caption: they'd probably look at you a little bit
Caption: weird and have no idea what you were
Caption: talking about
Caption: so it's not something that designers
Caption: talk about in their day-to-day but it's
Caption: a great concept to help explain the
Caption: broad landscape of design
Caption: so our first order here is called
Caption: symbols and this is all about visual
Caption: communication and it's most often the
Caption: area that people associate with design
Caption: so this is all about the visual things
Caption: people can see so this has things like
Caption: illustration typography photography
Caption: posters all of that sort of good stuff
Caption: and it's everything that's related to
Caption: the world of graphic design visual
Caption: design and information design
Caption: our second order here is called products
Caption: and this is where objects this includes
Caption: objects that people physically interact
Caption: with this is where Form and Function
Caption: meet
Caption: it's a world of product design and
Caption: Industrial design
Caption: and just to confuse things a little bit
Caption: more because everybody's already
Caption: confused about design so hey ho physical
Caption: product design does not equal digital
Caption: product design so this sits in our next
Caption: order which is
Caption: our order of interactions and this deals
Caption: with the experience of people and things
Caption: over time
Caption: so it's often tied in with our first
Caption: order of design and that's where you see
Caption: our user interface elements appear but
Caption: it delivers on interactions services and
Caption: experiences
Caption: so this is our world of service design
Caption: user experience design ux design or and
Caption: digital product design
Caption: and now we're in our fourth order this
Caption: is called systems and this is our most
Caption: complex order of all and in this we're
Caption: designing for things like businesses
Caption: learning experiences systems cultures
Caption: organizations and even cities
Caption: so this is a this is about how groups of
Caption: people and things interact with other
Caption: groups of people and things and this is
Caption: our world of strategic design business
Caption: design and organizational design
Caption: now this is all well and good and I
Caption: always love a good framework but let's
Caption: have a look at this in action
Caption: we're going to talk about Apple okay so
Caption: um I've done this I've practiced this
Caption: talk a few times and I've had some
Caption: positive and negative reactions whenever
Caption: I mention Apple to people so can I get a
Caption: hands up for who's an Apple fan in the
Caption: audience who digs Apple here
Caption: got a few people thought they might be
Caption: coming to a design talk
Caption: um who's not a fan who's like Boo his
Caption: Bad Apple yeah yeah
Caption: and who's ambivalent who's like yeah
Caption: yeah awesome okay we've got a good
Caption: mixture in here so this is going to be
Caption: good
Caption: um this isn't sponsored by Apple by the
Caption: way but if anybody is in the audience
Caption: like I'm always open to some freebies so
Caption: that's good
Caption: so we're going to go back into our
Caption: orders here we're going to talk about
Caption: our first orders order of design which
Caption: is symbols or visual communication
Caption: so in the 1990s Apple was actually in a
Caption: pretty bad State people actually thought
Caption: the company was going to go under there
Caption: was no iPhone there was no iPod there
Caption: was no iPad no iMac and then while Steve
Caption: Jobs waited on these products to launch
Caption: he wanted something that would remind
Caption: people about the qualities that were
Caption: caught the Apple brand
Caption: and this is where our think different
Caption: campaign comes in so here you'll see one
Caption: of the print ads that was uh that was
Caption: created and there were a whole series of
Caption: print ads that went with this as well as
Caption: a television commercial
Caption: and it's really powerful because here
Caption: you can um because of the emotions and
Caption: memories that this actually conveys so
Caption: there's no product shots here there's no
Caption: talk of any product benefits there's
Caption: just three things a historical figure
Caption: the Apple logo and the words think
Caption: different
Caption: so this is a branding campaign pure and
Caption: simple and it's one of the most popular
Caption: Apple campaigns to this day
Caption: so now we're looking at our second order
Caption: here and this is our order of products
Caption: or physical objects so here we're
Caption: designing two a broader set of
Caption: challenges which might mean materials
Caption: supply chain Logistics do I need to
Caption: change my microphone yep
Caption: that's okay
Caption: this will take up some of the 45 minutes
Caption: which is good okay cool
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um right here we are designing to a
Caption: broader set of challenges so you're
Caption: looking at things like materials supply
Caption: chain Logistics ergonomics packaging and
Caption: more
Caption: so the Apple packaging itself is a
Caption: sensory experience your first
Caption: interaction with this thing is actually
Caption: how it looks pack this packaging is
Caption: designed to be as visually appealing as
Caption: the thing that sits inside it
Caption: so every line on this box is clean it's
Caption: elegant it's minimalist it's white
Caption: packaging it's simple in a world of
Caption: clutter
Caption: so Apple actually pay attention as much
Caption: attention to the small stuff as they do
Caption: the big stuff so that box that gets the
Caption: same amount of attention as the device
Caption: inside it
Caption: so did you know that there's actually a
Caption: designer or designers that are employed
Caption: to create design and test hundreds of
Caption: prototype boxes so this just isn't about
Caption: Aesthetics here it's also about a
Caption: package that's easy for customers to
Caption: open it's easy for them to identify the
Caption: components parts inside it and it's easy
Caption: for them to start using so it's a
Caption: process that's focused first and
Caption: foremost on the customer it's not
Caption: focused on for example to prevent
Caption: shoplifting
Caption: now we're getting into our third order
Caption: here and this is our order of
Caption: interactions and services now I'm going
Caption: to spend a little bit more time talking
Caption: about this order because it's probably
Caption: where most of your designers will
Caption: actually be working in
Caption: so we're going to think about the
Caption: experience of buying from an Apple Store
Caption: from a physical store so you're going to
Caption: have a trigger there's going to be
Caption: something that makes you want to buy
Caption: that Apple product maybe it's an ad that
Caption: you've seen maybe it's a friend of a
Caption: family member that you've been
Caption: recommended it from
Caption: um you'll do some research you'll make
Caption: your way to the store maybe you're
Caption: catching a train
Caption: you'll enter the store you'll talk to
Caption: somebody about what you're after you'll
Caption: purchase your Apple product you'll leave
Caption: the store you'll go home you'll open up
Caption: the box
Caption: so this whole end to end experience and
Caption: these touch points and interactions and
Caption: emotions that are what we're designing
Caption: for in this order
Caption: so in this order our designers look at
Caption: three main areas we've got people
Caption: process and Technology
Caption: so first of all the people so it's not
Caption: just about the customers but the people
Caption: that work at Apple
Caption: this is about maintaining empathy for
Caption: everybody that's involved in the process
Caption: and so by trying to understand all sides
Caption: we can make human-centered critical
Caption: decisions in designing the experience
Caption: and we also look at process so these are
Caption: the standard procedures to operate a
Caption: business so for this apple example we'll
Caption: look at things like how do the staff
Caption: talk and interact with the customers so
Caption: what are their selling tactics how are
Caption: the staff rostered on for example what
Caption: happens during peak hours
Caption: and what are the different roles in the
Caption: store who does what
Caption: and by understanding the current process
Caption: and the business requirements we can
Caption: align and arm people in the business
Caption: with the knowledge and the tools to help
Caption: improve the experience
Caption: and the third one we look at is
Caption: technology so what's needed to deliver
Caption: the experience
Caption: so what technology is Apple using to
Caption: help deliver the service seamlessly so
Caption: do they have an efficient point of sale
Caption: system are we tracking deliveries once
Caption: they leave the store or the warehouse we
Caption: look at technology so we can actually
Caption: understand what are the touch points to
Caption: deliver the service and what can be done
Caption: to deliver a better improved service
Caption: now we're getting into our fourth order
Caption: this is our fourth order of design where
Caption: we're reaching into business design and
Caption: innovation
Caption: so apple is in fact a service business
Caption: it's got everything from the App Store
Caption: too and I'm going to take a breath here
Caption: Apple news Apple Books Apple TV Apple
Caption: movies Apple music Apple pay iclouds
Caption: iTunes and much more
Caption: right so this is where it gets its
Caption: Revenue so it's not just about selling
Caption: laptops and phones
Caption: it's about selling people constant
Caption: ongoing subscriptions for the things
Caption: that they can do on their devices
Caption: it's an ecosystem that's designed to
Caption: suck you in and never let you leave so
Caption: by buying that iPhone it's almost like
Caption: that gateway drug into the Apple
Caption: experience
Caption: so Apple innovate through reinvention
Caption: and they just make it slick so they want
Caption: to take Innovation to the next level by
Caption: making its product features better and
Caption: to work seamlessly across multiple
Caption: devices
Caption: so this leads us to now how Apple
Caption: designs their business for innovation
Caption: so in 1997 when jobs returned to Apple
Caption: this had a conventional structure this
Caption: is a structure that you see on the left
Caption: here it was divided into those business
Caption: units
Caption: so he changed it to the structure on the
Caption: right where the organization was
Caption: restructured to align to areas of
Caption: expertise and since Tim Cook has taken
Caption: over it has changed slightly again
Caption: so they rely on organizational design to
Caption: have a crucial part in the success for
Caption: Innovation where they're able to compete
Caption: with other companies like Google Samsung
Caption: Microsoft IBM and many more
Caption: but if you're anything like me
Caption: you probably still have questions like
Caption: when did things start getting so
Caption: complicated when do we start needing all
Caption: of these different types of designers
Caption: and when did they start popping up in
Caption: all of these different organizations
Caption: so I blame the year 2013 right so I want
Caption: you to think back to 2013 and think
Caption: about what you were doing
Caption: it was almost a decade ago it was a very
Caption: non-pandemic type of time it was a much
Caption: simpler time back then but it's got a
Caption: lot to answer for now I didn't know if
Caption: I'd be losing people at this point so
Caption: you've hit the funny GIF and memes
Caption: section of my talk which is cool so 2013
Caption: was when this guy came into office so he
Caption: was our 28th prime minister like I said
Caption: 2013 had a lot to answer for thanks to
Caption: Miley twerking first entered the Oxford
Caption: dictionary so that's actually in the
Caption: dictionary now thanks to her
Caption: the worst wedding ever happened on Game
Caption: of Thrones my partner's now making me
Caption: re-watch all the Game of Thrones series
Caption: at the moment so I thought that was
Caption: quite apt
Caption: um and back in 2013 I read a wide
Caption: magazine article which at the time I
Caption: didn't think too much of I thought I
Caption: thought that's interesting I wonder
Caption: what's going to happen off of that and
Caption: just sort of moved on with my day
Caption: but little did I know that that was
Caption: actually a key moment in terms of what
Caption: design meant or represented to
Caption: businesses
Caption: so this is what it was uh entitled it
Caption: was called Big corporations are buying
Caption: design firms in droves
Caption: right and the first opening line in this
Caption: was the significance of does in of
Caption: design in business is ballooning
Caption: so 2013 is the year that Accenture a
Caption: global consulting firm buys design giant
Caption: Fjord so Fjord are a london-based global
Caption: design and Innovation firm
Caption: now bigger companies have been acquiring
Caption: smaller companies since forever but it
Caption: was about this time that design agencies
Caption: and firms started to become acquired by
Caption: large consultant companies and so it
Caption: wasn't just large advertising marketing
Caption: and creative groups
Caption: and so fast forward to today so design
Caption: has changed it's now been recognized by
Caption: companies and businesses as something
Caption: that can provide Better Business and
Caption: customer outcomes
Caption: and so what this means is now we're
Caption: seeing a change in the type of designers
Caption: that we're seeing in organizations so
Caption: say about 10 years ago there were much
Caption: more visual digital and web designers
Caption: and now you're seeing more strategic
Caption: experience and service designers
Caption: so what does this mean for you right the
Caption: projects that you work on and the
Caption: designers that you actually work with
Caption: so it not only comes down to
Caption: understanding what is design all of
Caption: those cool for for orders that we've
Caption: just gone through
Caption: but it's about getting a rough idea of
Caption: what the design process is like and
Caption: where different designers can crop up in
Caption: your process
Caption: now when we talk through the process
Caption: today I'll mainly be talking through our
Caption: third order of design so this is mainly
Caption: when we're dealing with ux designers
Caption: service designers product designers Etc
Caption: so this is my area the area that I sit
Caption: in and most of the like I said before
Caption: where most of your designers will
Caption: probably sit in
Caption: so this is what it looks like when
Caption: you've got designers usually explaining
Caption: design processes we tend to look a
Caption: little bit like that
Caption: that does feel like there's like a
Caption: million different design Frameworks and
Caption: methodologies out there out there that
Caption: step through this process but
Caption: um but the easiest one and the most
Caption: common one we tend to refer to
Caption: is our good old Double Diamond and this
Caption: is great because you can chuck in Double
Caption: Diamond into Google and this you know is
Caption: generally what you'll get back so
Caption: it was done in 2004 it was created by
Caption: the UK design Council and it's very well
Caption: known with designers so if you ever want
Caption: to talk to a designer about this they
Caption: can run you through it so it basically
Caption: describes our two modes of thinking that
Caption: we do as designers this is where we're
Caption: going wide we're diverging so you can
Caption: see I'll do a clothesline and then we'll
Caption: converge and we'll go narrow
Caption: might be a new speaker post who knows
Caption: um so the first diamond is really about
Caption: if we're figuring out if we're doing the
Caption: right things right so this is why we're
Caption: going to go wide with our Discovery
Caption: search we're going to converge and we're
Caption: going to go narrow we're going to Define
Caption: our research themes our insights and our
Caption: opportunity areas
Caption: and then we're going to go into our
Caption: second Diamond so this is about building
Caption: the things right so we go wide we
Caption: diverge we go wide with our ideas we're
Caption: starting to set the design Vision a
Caption: North star and then we're going to
Caption: converge and we're going to go narrow
Caption: and this is where we're prototyping
Caption: we're testing we're learning we're
Caption: iterating we're rinsing and repeating
Caption: until hazar we have our solution
Caption: but I have a problem with this approach
Caption: it's to design Centric
Caption: I think it's useful because it gives all
Caption: the good stuff that you get with
Caption: converging and diverging Etc but it
Caption: suggests that we've actually got a final
Caption: solution at the end that accepts up the
Caption: expectation that everything's completed
Caption: and it's handed off for implementation
Caption: to our Dev teams
Caption: that last diamond is way too simplified
Caption: in the real world of delivery
Caption: so this is why I personally prefer the
Caption: triple diamond which was produced by
Caption: zendesk and this is what it looks like
Caption: so at the start of our third Diamond
Caption: here we're confident it's the right
Caption: solution at this point we've gone
Caption: through our Discovery process and we
Caption: know it's there but it needs further
Caption: refinement so let's zoom into this last
Caption: Diamond a little bit more
Caption: there we go
Caption: um this diamond actually marks the start
Caption: of our agile Sprints where we're
Caption: building out our products through to our
Caption: launch and it's not about doing a
Caption: handoff
Caption: here we're refining and we're filling in
Caption: more details as we're progressing
Caption: through our Sprints and our Des are
Caption: investigating Technical Solutions while
Caption: our designers are creating prototypes
Caption: and conducting usability tests
Caption: and as we progress we can see the
Caption: uncertainty is decreasing over time and
Caption: we're honing into that right solution
Caption: and we're still testing throughout just
Caption: to see how customers are responding
Caption: through our product so this test and
Caption: respond and we're tweaking accordingly
Caption: and as we progress uncertainty is
Caption: decreasing over time and we're starting
Caption: to hone into that right solution
Caption: now we should be refining our solution
Caption: as we're progressing we're really
Caption: starting to hone in but towards the end
Caption: that flexibility for change decreases
Caption: and at the end it's that last little
Caption: bits of optimizations that we're
Caption: actually accounting for
Caption: now it's important to remember and
Caption: anyone that's been involved in this
Caption: process it's never linear it feels a
Caption: little bit messy sometimes sometimes
Caption: there's features that you may discover
Caption: that need to go back into the discovery
Caption: process for example
Caption: so now we've got a good understanding of
Caption: the process let's talk about some of the
Caption: different designers you'll get across
Caption: this process and where do they sit
Caption: I'm going to take a bit of water here
Caption: just
Caption: hold on
Caption: right so now we're back into our Triple
Caption: Diamond the full triple diamond and here
Caption: it's an example of what our hbf projects
Caption: look like and how our designers sit in
Caption: the process so we're actually in that
Caption: last little validation stage at the
Caption: moment
Caption: so our service designers and our ux
Caption: researchers are performing heuristic
Caption: reviews and assessments with some squads
Caption: and our in-squad product designers are
Caption: ux uis are working through bug fixes and
Caption: improvements
Caption: so as a team we're actually honing in on
Caption: our final solution but our flexibility
Caption: for changes definitely decreasing as
Caption: we're getting closer to our rollout
Caption: so let's talk about collaborating with
Caption: designers in this process so it's really
Caption: important to remember that designers
Caption: don't hold the Monopoly over how we
Caption: design and build products or even how we
Caption: innovate
Caption: remember we need to collaborate with our
Caption: experts with you guys and ladies and
Caption: gents and everyone in this room
Caption: so the reason why we need you
Caption: we need to make sure that we're design
Caption: what we're designing is not only
Caption: desirable but it's also feasible to
Caption: create and viable for the business
Caption: so if there's no collaboration there we
Caption: end up missing two key areas our
Caption: feasibility and our viability
Caption: so Innovation and great products can't
Caption: happen in isolation and it's certainly
Caption: not about throwing things over the fence
Caption: and designing and developing without
Caption: collaboration so collaboration is key to
Caption: creating Innovative products and
Caption: services
Caption: uh so for those that are interested this
Caption: is what we call a dvf framework
Caption: um it also is referred to as three
Caption: lenses of innovation and it was done by
Caption: originally a company called Ideo and
Caption: there's been a lot of talk recently
Caption: about a fourth lens uh this is for
Caption: sustainability and this is where we're
Caption: looking at including social and
Caption: environmental awarenesses into our
Caption: designs as well
Caption: right let's go through some practical
Caption: tips because I'm all about practical
Caption: tips that can help improve collaboration
Caption: with your designers
Caption: so first see your design team as your
Caption: true partner in crime so we can help you
Caption: understand customer needs and can help
Caption: you influence the product design and
Caption: direction
Caption: and provide constructive feedback so we
Caption: love getting good useful
Caption: um feedback and fresh ideas but it needs
Caption: to be delivered in a way which is
Caption: actually useful so things like I love it
Caption: is always great but making sure you tell
Caption: us why you love it the same thing goes
Caption: with uh I don't like it to make sure
Caption: that you've got um that backing there
Caption: for why you don't like it
Caption: so providing a reasonable always help
Caption: your designers but you need to make sure
Caption: it's with the lens of your customer make
Caption: sure it's objective feedback and if
Caption: you've got the data there to support it
Caption: even better
Caption: so be upfront about constraints so your
Caption: designers should be getting feedback
Caption: from you throughout the design process
Caption: and if they're not definitely hit them
Caption: up about that
Caption: speak up about Technical and business
Caption: constraints as well so when we know
Caption: about these it helps us work with you to
Caption: find an alternative solution
Caption: but it's really important to be
Caption: considerate and to make sure that
Caption: upfront constraints don't stifle
Caption: creativity and Innovation so make sure
Caption: you work with your designers as a team
Caption: to overcome those constraints
Caption: review design work thoroughly so this is
Caption: especially true for our visual designers
Caption: so Details Matter here right they may
Caption: your designers may think that the
Caption: Specter everything but more than likely
Caption: they have actually missed something
Caption: so the same thing goes for those that
Caption: are working with Design Systems
Caption: so make sure you're factoring it in time
Caption: with your feedback quite often we work
Caption: hand to mouth especially when we're
Caption: working in squads right where all the
Caption: deliverables are really urgent but this
Caption: actually leads to problems later on so
Caption: when suddenly it just becomes a just get
Caption: it done sort of scenario we may miss
Caption: opportunities for things that need to be
Caption: tested
Caption: now out of all of these points if
Caption: there's any one point that's probably
Caption: the most important this is it this is
Caption: about getting involved so observe your
Caption: research sessions make the time to
Caption: observe them listen to the customer
Caption: feedback and even your debriefs from
Caption: your designers
Caption: so discuss with them what are their next
Caption: steps highlight any technical or
Caption: business constraints and but leave it
Caption: with them to make the design decisions
Caption: right so I actually know I've got a few
Caption: designers in the audience today so I
Caption: don't think I haven't forgotten about
Caption: you
Caption: and hopefully some are watching online
Caption: as well
Caption: now just think
Caption: what if you gave the same care and
Caption: attention to the people that you work
Caption: with as you do your end users right so
Caption: find out the pain points and needs for
Caption: the people that you work with so talk to
Caption: them take them out for coffee maybe beer
Caption: or wine always open for that maybe some
Caption: people like something a little bit more
Caption: formal
Caption: I've even seen designers use empathy
Caption: Maps before to better understand their
Caption: teammates
Caption: so understand maybe the pressures that
Caption: your product owner is under so what
Caption: metrics are important to them what are
Caption: they trying to achieve
Caption: what are the pain points for your
Caption: developers is rework a problem for them
Caption: what's going to make their life a lot
Caption: easier
Caption: so by understanding the people that you
Caption: work with just as well as you do your
Caption: users you can actually establish better
Caption: workflows that will provide better
Caption: outcomes and will end up having a better
Caption: happier working relationships
Caption: so be like Bruce Lee this is very Zen be
Caption: like Bruce Lee be flexible like water
Caption: so your design documentation some
Caption: workflows will change from Project to
Caption: project from Team to team and you need
Caption: to adapt to what what works best for
Caption: your team
Caption: so your team shouldn't adapt to you I
Caption: mean sure sometimes you may have
Caption: suggestions to actually uh how a
Caption: different approach may help everything
Caption: but in general we're a piece of a larger
Caption: puzzle so be like water be adaptable
Caption: your desire will never be done sounds a
Caption: little bit depressing but this is where
Caption: you need to be strong this is where
Caption: resilience is key so as a designer our
Caption: job isn't done once our screens and
Caption: prototypes are dumb you're going to find
Caption: that the real Challenge and I'm finding
Caption: this at the moment is when people start
Caption: poking around in your designs
Caption: discovering holes and use cases that you
Caption: haven't even thought of
Caption: and so as this happens you need to make
Caption: sure that you work harder to accommodate
Caption: these requirements iterating on your
Caption: designs
Caption: so our role this is because our role as
Caption: designers is to create experiences that
Caption: people actually use it's not about
Caption: creating mock-ups or concepts
Caption: so we need to be responsible for the
Caption: things we create we're an important part
Caption: of what is produced and used by the
Caption: people that we champion
Caption: because of this we're going to
Caption: continually keep iterating and improving
Caption: and evolving our designs and they'll
Caption: never be done but at the end of the day
Caption: that's a great thing
Caption: so it's not just about design either so
Caption: how can designers help make sure that we
Caption: deliver on a great product so this is
Caption: where we're going to get our hands dirty
Caption: and we're going to help provide feedback
Caption: on what's being built
Caption: so for example the designers in our web
Caption: Squad at the moment over at HBS have
Caption: been doing device testing and I've had a
Caption: heap of people come up to me going but
Caption: why are you guys doing testing like
Caption: doesn't that sit with the developers and
Caption: the testers
Caption: um but designers actually have an
Caption: intimate knowledge of the product of the
Caption: end user and what should be built right
Caption: and they know how those dots connect
Caption: throughout that whole end-to-end
Caption: experience so use that to your advantage
Caption: so designers this means you might have
Caption: to get intimate with things like for
Caption: example jira make sure the acceptance
Caption: criteria is correct make sure that that
Caption: link in that ticket is linking through
Caption: to your figma file or your sketch file
Caption: make sure those screenshots are correct
Caption: so all of these things work to help your
Caption: team and also help make sure that you
Caption: deliver on a great product and
Caption: experience
Caption: so less is more
Caption: so as we desire as designers we design
Caption: for an ideal state right our future
Caption: state so in the real world not all of
Caption: our features will make it into our MVP
Caption: our minimal viable product that's built
Caption: at the end
Caption: so as the project progresses you're
Caption: going to find that your product owner is
Caption: going to prioritize features and as this
Caption: happens designers are going to see their
Caption: work shrink and shrink and shrink and
Caption: Shrink until everything's sort of thrown
Caption: over at the end of the day at the end of
Caption: the boat so this is where a design
Caption: mindset change is needed so this should
Caption: be seen as an opportunity rather than an
Caption: attack so we can really work to refine
Caption: out these MVP features and really make
Caption: sure that we're working closely with our
Caption: teams to build this out
Caption: now just like the last a lot of points
Caption: that I went through if there's any one
Caption: that you want to take away with you this
Caption: is probably it it's about bringing our
Caption: teams along for the ride
Caption: and see there's a roller coaster there
Caption: haha
Caption: um so sometimes our teams aren't
Caption: involved in our Discovery process
Caption: sometimes they don't get to see things
Caption: like usability tests or hear from our
Caption: end users right
Caption: so as designers we represent the voice
Caption: of the customer we've got a really
Caption: important part in making sure that
Caption: goodness spreads across our teams
Caption: so it might be things like playing back
Caption: verbatim feedback that we've had in our
Caption: user testing sessions we may present
Caption: test results back in some things like uh
Caption: we've got showcases for example at hbf
Caption: we play back our research findings and
Caption: those and if you're able to play back
Caption: videos where people can hear it from the
Caption: horse's mouth that's even better
Caption: so where you can make sure you involve
Caption: your teams so it's really difficult
Caption: sometimes because there is a tension
Caption: between just getting the stuff done
Caption: making sure we're achieving our Sprint
Caption: goals making sure we're getting that
Caption: burn down looking really good
Caption: but in the bigger picture we're going to
Caption: have products that provide a better
Caption: experiences for our teams if they know
Caption: who they're designing them for and who
Caption: they're building them for as well
Caption: so as designers it's not just about us
Caption: understanding our end users it's also
Caption: the role of the business to understand
Caption: the end users and as designers we need
Caption: to make sure we're better at spreading
Caption: and sharing that knowledge and
Caption: understanding of our customers
Caption: so these tactics that I've talked
Caption: through are really aimed at improving
Caption: collaboration right so we know that
Caption: collaboration is really key for high
Caption: performing cross-functional teams but it
Caption: also improves something that we call
Caption: Design maturity so what is design
Caption: maturity
Caption: so design maturity is the way to which
Caption: business businesses incorporate
Caption: understand and use design
Caption: so the more mature an organization the
Caption: more likely that Innovation better
Caption: customer experiences and business
Caption: benefits will happen
Caption: so there's been a bunch of reports and
Caption: models that have been done on design
Caption: maturity there's been one through the
Caption: Nielsen Norman group that's very ux
Caption: focused there was one three years ago
Caption: through a company called Envision and
Caption: one done about five years ago through
Caption: McKinsey
Caption: so we're going to have a quick look at
Caption: the Envision maturity scale here
Caption: so this is the maturity scale that was
Caption: done by Envision so here you can see as
Caption: we move through different levels of
Caption: design maturity so they're those big
Caption: dots you see on the screen there the
Caption: benefits of design and the adoption of
Caption: design in the business increase
Caption: so these circles represent the
Caption: proportions of businesses for each of
Caption: these maturity stages in the study so
Caption: for example that little dot that you see
Caption: at the top right there that shows that
Caption: five percent of comp companies were at
Caption: the top level of design maturity so in
Caption: this study that's 110 businesses out of
Caption: 2 200.
Caption: so let's look at each of these levels
Caption: let's go into our level ones so these
Caption: had the lowest level of design maturity
Caption: but they actually make up the largest
Caption: proportion at 41
Caption: so these are the companies where design
Caption: is just seen as pixels on a screen
Caption: so here there's a real disconnect
Caption: between what designers design and what
Caption: developers actually produce and so this
Caption: is a symptom of a lack of collaboration
Caption: when we hit our level two so this is a
Caption: level twos we're at 21 here this is
Caption: where collaboration with these
Caption: organizations was improving where
Caption: designers and non-designers are starting
Caption: to work together a lot more
Caption: so here you're seeing uh more things
Caption: like integrated tooling user research
Caption: user testing you're probably seeing some
Caption: personas around the business
Caption: and you're generally hearing a lot more
Caption: chit chat about design in the business
Caption: now we're going to look at our level
Caption: threes here they're at 21 as well but
Caption: this is where design starts to become
Caption: scalable where there's established
Caption: things like processes roles
Caption: responsibilities documentation all of
Caption: that sort of stuff so this is where
Caption: design operates in more complex
Caption: companies and product ecosystems
Caption: so with level threes you're seeing more
Caption: things like Design Systems written
Caption: briefs
Caption: um and More Design ceremonies
Caption: when we look at our level fours so this
Caption: is where we're starting to get a little
Caption: bit smaller here this is a 12 of
Caption: companies in this survey that um
Caption: envisioned them
Caption: so this is where you're starting to see
Caption: a lot more design experimentation and
Caption: it's all about data driven design
Caption: so this is where you're probably
Caption: starting to see the starts of a design
Caption: strategy practice this is where you're
Caption: probably going to see more market
Caption: research and design Vision development
Caption: and happening and you're probably seeing
Caption: design operations being formalized to
Caption: support the design practice as well
Caption: and our last Little Dot at the top there
Caption: that's our level five so this is nirvana
Caption: right so this is level five it sounded
Caption: really Australian Nirvana anyway
Caption: um this is our ultimate level of design
Caption: maturity right this is only where five
Caption: percent of the companies in the survey
Caption: were playing so this is where design is
Caption: actually used to help business strategy
Caption: where we're doing exploratory user
Caption: research we're doing Trend spotting and
Caption: Futures research we're experimenting
Caption: we're testing for product Market fit and
Caption: producing things like Vision artifacts
Caption: so the majority of places that I've
Caption: worked at I'd say would be between a
Caption: level one and three so that's not a bad
Caption: thing it just means design as a function
Caption: in the business is in its early days
Caption: and so it's really important to remember
Caption: you can't just jump from a level one to
Caption: a level five if only if it was that easy
Caption: it's a real gradual progression that
Caption: requires a huge amount of effort and a
Caption: lot of the the business are buying from
Caption: uh the business as well so it can take
Caption: years to move from one stage to the next
Caption: but it happens every day in still in
Caption: small steps I do seem to remember off
Caption: the top of my head but don't quote me I
Caption: think it takes probably about 30 years
Caption: possibly to reach a level five
Caption: organization
Caption: so aside from collaboration what can
Caption: help right so here are some tips from
Caption: that report and some examples of what
Caption: we've been doing over at hbf
Caption: so design needs to be supported at a
Caption: leadership level so when it's seen as
Caption: more than just pixels on a screen and
Caption: it's recognized it's a part of the
Caption: business a critical part of the business
Caption: there's opportunity to use design to
Caption: innovate
Caption: so it's something that we do have at hbf
Caption: so we've got support from our general
Caption: managers in the business and we've got
Caption: an executive general manager of member
Caption: experience
Caption: so they actually understand and speak to
Caption: the value of design and so having this
Caption: support actually means that hpf has
Caption: actually adopted design and see it as
Caption: key for improving the customer and
Caption: member experiences
Caption: so higher experience design leaders
Caption: right isn't this typically what you
Caption: think of a designer you know wearing
Caption: black glasses and a black outfit
Caption: the more senior a design leadership the
Caption: greater the return on the design
Caption: investment so who should you be hiring
Caption: for right so you need design leaders
Caption: that know their craft they can Inspire
Caption: their team and they can make a strong
Caption: case for design at the highest levels of
Caption: business
Caption: so at hbf we've got a chapter lead and
Caption: we've also got a gem of member
Caption: experience strategy and they're part of
Caption: those critical conversations and this
Caption: actually gives design a voice in the
Caption: business where it can actually be used
Caption: to transform the business
Caption: and use design to run regular
Caption: experiments and use data to inform
Caption: strategy so companies can innovate when
Caption: they use design and data to explore
Caption: experiment inform and your risk right so
Caption: an example of where we've used design
Caption: experiments at hbf is what's in our
Caption: future State service design work
Caption: so this is where we were able to connect
Caption: the dots between the design strategy and
Caption: the business strategy where we were able
Caption: to prove that we could get efficiency
Caption: gains and cost savings right so for
Caption: example we were able to identify that 20
Caption: of our online sales for hbf were
Caption: actually members trying to change their
Caption: level of cover and so this informed our
Caption: design strategy where we've prototyped
Caption: and experimented with solutions for this
Caption: and then we also identified that we
Caption: could provide cost savings to hbf where
Caption: we've hypothesized that there will be
Caption: decreases in manual handling costs and
Caption: the number of calls into our cost center
Caption: and so moving forward we know that these
Caption: are also metrics that we want to measure
Caption: and spread design throughout the
Caption: business so when design works at scale
Caption: and it's embedded within the
Caption: organization it's going to have more
Caption: impact and influence so our design
Caption: practice over at hbf is still pretty
Caption: young and we're looking at still
Caption: establishing things like processes and
Caption: design standards and building out things
Caption: like our design system and these are
Caption: going to help us work at scale and
Caption: that's exactly what happens when you see
Caption: design maturity trying to build in an
Caption: organization
Caption: and so what we do start seeing we do
Caption: have signs of design culture throughout
Caption: hbf so we're seeing things like we've
Caption: got to design an experience chapter
Caption: we've got business capabilities that are
Caption: actually aligned to our customer Journey
Caption: we've got an established research
Caption: program and we've got a guiding value
Caption: proposition and design principles and
Caption: these were actually created through
Caption: things like research concept testing
Caption: experts and employees that were
Caption: interviewed and there are North staff
Caption: for our design work
Caption: foreign
Caption: so the design profession is still
Caption: evolving so only in the last 10 years
Caption: the last decade have we seen designers a
Caption: way to actually drive business success
Caption: and also to be used to solve for complex
Caption: human issues
Caption: so we need to make sure we still don't
Caption: lose our producers and across people
Caption: these are a design Specialists that sit
Caption: in those first two orders but we need to
Caption: also have our strategists and our
Caption: Visionaries who work and thrive in
Caption: complexity especially in that fourth
Caption: order
Caption: and as technology continues to grow and
Caption: change so will Design
Caption: so as a fun fact some people may have
Caption: spotted this the majority of the images
Caption: I've used in this presentation were
Caption: actually done through mid-journey it's
Caption: an AI image generator so things like
Caption: artificial intelligence virtual reality
Caption: the metaverse and automation are going
Caption: to have huge impacts on design in the
Caption: future
Caption: and so as we're facing into a more
Caption: complex world and as it starts to change
Caption: faster than ever before designers are
Caption: well placed to help for the soul for the
Caption: big messy problems faces that come with
Caption: this
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]